record
[Music]
[Laughter]
my sister and i we wanted to be on
the cover of this very popular
magazine we were told
that we couldn't be on the cover of the
magazine
because we were black and we would not
sell how someone could demean your value
because of the color of your skin
i will never forget that
i'm tia mori and today i am unfiltered
from my home
how long does it take me to do my makeup
i'm a mom
right i'm a working mom so
i like to do my makeup in about 20 to 25
minutes
any time past that i'm out
you know i've been quarantined for
a while now but i will say this
when i do get out which is the grocery
store
or an important doctor's appointment i
will i think they
say i will beat my face to the gods
before i like to apply any kind of
makeup
you know i think it's really important
to me to mention
that skin care is essential
right i believe it's all about the
inside
and out when it comes to beautiful skin
and i actually have a supplement line
called answer and it's all about
skin hair and nails so i like to take
that
and another thing that i like to do is i
love
to moisturize my skin
it's all about the glow
oh i'm a nut when you put me in front of
a camera i'm a nut okay
especially if i'm looking at myself i
can't be serious in front of a camera
i'm
moisturize moisturize moisturized
and i like to go up like that because
when you go down
see how it drags your face down and it's
all about
[Music]
when was the first time i recognized
beauty
i would have to say looking at my mother
she
is this strong confident
beautiful black woman and she has
beautiful dark skin and her skin is just
so smooth
she's the epitome of beauty
[Music]
my parents my dad's white my mom's black
and my parents they actually met
in high school they ended up getting
married very young you guys
and both of them enlisted in the army
people in general who are in the army
they move around
a lot so that's exactly
what happened with me
moving around a lot especially as a
child it was hard
because i would kind of
you know go to school get new friends
and then
i would have to leave and bounce and
then i would have to start that process
all over again i truly believe that
that's why i'm a social butterfly today
and i actually have a butterfly tattoo
i've learned how to
make friends be social because
it was kind of like the only way to
survive
you know as a child
so i'm gonna take you guys down memory
lane
with some sister sister fashion
i'm scared
i'll tell you this i know exactly what's
going on in that picture
my sister and myself we probably said go
home
roger our outfits in my opinion
i think it's still in style i mean what
i love
is we platted it if that's even a word
i think i would definitely rock the
plaid tights again i think that's cool
you know what i mean
classic oh
[Applause]
terrible that was just wrong just
all wrong number one the clothes were
just too baggy remember
back in the day remember back then like
it was all about the baggy clothes you
know
no no no i mean the hats were cute
the hats were cute i actually have um a
hat like that still in my closet
today i'd wear the hat but everything
else know
oh my gosh i love that photo
you know what i love about that photo
it's the memories
that came with that photo that was
one of my biggest photo shoots that i
had
ever done in my entire life and that
photo
was actually um when sister sister was
on abc
a huge huge moment so i was just so
excited
we got to try on clothes people got to
do our hair
our makeup i love that photo
actually i forgot a tip you guys so i
like to
put a little bit of a highlighter like
right in between there
just to kind of highlight my eyebrows a
little bit
just to kind of give it like a little
more definitions
okay so after that what i like to do is
i like to start with my concealer
i think by me being a twin
i i truly feel like you always
know what's going on you always know
what's happening
whether you want to or not you know
being a twin
you're kind of always linked together
i'll give you guys an example so
if i'm at a grocery store and it's just
me
they'll be like hi tiantamira
you're like it's only me you know
sometimes it's really hard
to individualize yourself as
an individual person when you are twins
because people tend to always like
group you together and people think that
you like the same things you do
the same things but my sister and i
you know we're very different we usually
say we're like night and day
if i were really honest with you in the
beginning it was hard and it was more
about
not allowing society to define who we
were and are today and allowing us to
evolve into the people that
we really are and once we were able to
do that
i feel very blessed that people have
been able to
accept you know who we are as as
individuals
so since we're talking about foundation
i would say
the foundation of my life
is family family family
family family whenever i like
get into some sort of bind
meaning i'm kind of going through some
sort of tribulation
i always look to my ancestors and then i
looked to my family i looked to my
my children i looked to my my son my
daughter i looked to my husband
they they keep me strong they keep me
standing up straight
growing up in this industry and
you know being a young black girl
in the spotlight i was insecure
i used to take diet pills i would also
feel insecure
about my hair because
being young and being in this in this
business i never
saw girls like me i never saw girls
that you know were embracing
their curls or i never saw
curly hair being portrayed as beautiful
let's say that
i love that now i'm seeing images that's
really embracing natural beautiful curly
hair and just beautiful black women in
all shades dark light skin brown
representation is important and
that really helped me meaning me seeing
those images
is what helped me embrace my natural
beauty
i'm on contouring honey
oh my gosh
when was there a time that i wish i
would have spoken
up wow i don't know i'm about to cry
wow sorry
i don't want to ruin my makeup
okay
so it was around sister sister days
and the show was extremely popular we
were beating
like in the ratings friends around that
time
so my sister and i we wanted to be on
the cover of this very popular
magazine um at the time and it was a
teenage magazine
and we were told
that we couldn't be on the cover of the
magazine
because we were black and we would not
sell but here i am you know
as an adult and it's and it's and it's
sorry wow and it still affects me you
know
how someone could demean your value
because of the color of your skin
and i will never forget that i will
never forget
where i was um
and i wish i would have spoken i wish i
wish i would have said
something then i wish i would have
you know had the courage to you know
speak out and say that that that wasn't
right
and that's why even to this day i'm
always telling my
beautiful brown skinned girl hey girl
hey girl hate your baker
that she is beautiful i always tell
cairo
i always say cairo you are so beautiful
you're smart and the same thing even
with my son
i tell him how handsome he is he's
smart because i know what it feels like
for someone to that you've looked up to
for someone to devalue your worth
and i don't want my children to ever
ever ever feel that
and not have the strength or the
foundation to
not believe it to believe that they are
worthy and
my makeup is done
i feel most beautiful
when i am surrounded by my children
and my husband and just my family
and i'm just me i'm just
myself meaning no makeup
my hair is not done i'm just in
comfortable clothes and i'm
just me gray hairs
and all that is when i feel beautiful
amazing thank you